bringing random men into the home women
this this is like the greatest sin of
all sins bringing home a random man to
raise your daughters I really do not
believe that women should even try to
remarry I I really don't I really think
you made your bed you should give the
kid to the dad because imagine being
that woman's ex-husband I mean it's very
clear that whoever was her dad was not
in her life because she wouldn't be on o
or he wasn't a strong enough influence
to keep her out of that direction and
her stepfather clearly was encouraging
it and this is actually disgusting but
it also shows that the stepdad is one of
the most likely people to abuse the kid
okay